CNN feeling the heat after one of their
panels mocked and laughed at Trump
supporters here's Don lemons attempt to
clean it up I don't believe in
belittling people belittling anyone for
who they are or what they believe or
where they're from during an interview
on Saturday night one of my guests said
something that made me laugh and while
in the moment I found that joke humorous
and I didn't catch everything that was
said just to make this perfectly clear I
was laughing at the joke and not at any
group of people but that semi apology
has come too little too late
the RNC already launching this brutal ad
based off the segment and so that's
partly him playing to their base and
anyone who supported this president yes
you know the the the credulous Boomer
Rube demo that backs tunnel trunk this
wants to think that the dump trucks a
smart one in there oh yo-yo elitist her
okay well Katie we predicted this the
other day that there was going to be an
ad on that and there you have it so yep
do you buy Don lemons apology saying I
was only laughing at that initial joke
you next to a picture of a crane and not
all the other person well the joke about
how dumb Trump supporters are so that's
what he was laughing at and then this is
CNN's problem they never owned that they
are biased and I would argue that what
they were what he was laughing at and
what the guests were saying was not just
biased but was very bigoted can you
imagine if you on your show had a
segment and people were laughing and
making those kinds of comments about the
way people speak how dumb they are and
going after the same demographic for the
left of the left like going after very
specific kinds of people very specific
demographic graphic groups and the way
that they talk the way that they how
educated they are uneducated they are
and that they are stupid and that is why
they support a certain president that's
bigotry and the standard is double and
Ciena never just owns that they have
some kind of bent they act like they're
objective and Don Lemon is proving would
you consider that bigotry one no no it
was not directed at in terms of
anybody's race ethnicity religion it was
about what he what it definitely was oh
I don't think so I think was directed at
Trump supporters but it was like a
southern twang II you can Philly you can
go on with the grievance ok I get the
point
no because I think that that's why the
ad exists is because it really does play
to the whole notion of gee we poor
conservatives from supporters we're beat
up and I got evidence I don't think
that's evidence I think that one I you
know think Don Lemon is an opinion guy
I'm not sure that the apology did much
except dig the hole deeper I think he
should just own it and say this is what
I think but to your point I just think
that a lot of people you know especially
on the Democratic side have problems
with trying to understand unvarnished
unwavering support for a guy who has is
this off-putting and this
because they talk like that about Trump
supporters and don't make an effort to
go to the rally maybe have a
conversation no but he they're not he's
not attacking Trump he's attacking the
people who voted for him and support him
and they don't make any effort to get
out of their New York City bubble and to
go talk to me ironic Katie because the
boy do I see Republicans talk about skin
and lids mocking libs I mean you know
okay well listen it happens on all sides
but I think you know there were
Republicans confused about why Obama
voters could not see all the things that
you were showing them about his policies
or his behavior or whatever I mean both
sides have an adoring I guess love for
whoever the president is at the time
well I'm just wondering where the
Southern Poverty Law Center is on this
because that would be considered hey I
actually I disagree with you one on the
is this bigotry or is this not bigotry
and it says it's actually classism right
they're demeaning an entire class but
they're using a stereotypical accent
when they're demeaning the class which
is a form of bigotry they're talking
about white rednecks that's what they're
basically doing that's why they were
seeing a southern accent yeah it was
Rick Wilson the Republican yes exactly
but I think that there are black people
who speak like that
yeah and you know what maybe that's
where that maybe that's where CNN took
the stereotype from and applied it to
the whites maybe they just pushed it
over here that could be it look they
can't reconcile their feelings with the
world outside so the world has left them
behind and that's why they're having a
problem the Rick Wilson's of the world
they they're there now they're kind of
stuck in this feedback loop where all
they can do is go on CNN and put put out
they put out they invite you back and
that's all that was so Lemon kind of
hung them out to dry there but I don't I
don't look down on them
because I was them you know I was them I
was a never Trumper and then when he was
elected president I decided to give him
a chance
focus on the measurable results and not
the not the tweets and he's impressed me
and I've changed my tune and I don't
think I think that that the problem is
they can't do that yeah stuck in their
prison I actually made a similar point
when we were talking about this Ukraine
thing
was saying you could go out on the
street and you can ask anybody where
Ukraine is or will tell me about Ukraine
and actually did that and no one really
knew much about Ukraine and they didn't
really understand the controversy and
that's not demeaning the intelligence of
people that's just saying it doesn't
really rise to the level of something
that they care about emotionally as an
American it reminds me of in the 2000
election one of the reporters one you
might remember who it was asked george w
bush to name the president of Slovenia
and the whole narrative was this guy is
so dumb that he doesn't know who the
president of Slovenia is and no I can't
remember the other ones but it was just
reminds me of that unnecessary I don't
love the idea of you know like we could
be in ads right like they could take
clips from us because everything is gone
me Dana
everything will be okay that's they
never know I think I'm listen to Liz
Warren ad I think we've been in ads you
must have I wasn't a Jerry Nadler
fundraising email oh wow that's a creek
that's a great brag yeah I don't know
what's funny you man but I think I
should have a kind of on donated